for millions of students around the
world attending university is a time to
not only learn but also socialize for
some time to be carefree
but for many making it through
University depends on whether or not
they have a meal every day or lani
sacani is a postgraduate student at the
University of the Western Cape every
month he collects a parcel of basic
necessities like rice and canned
vegetables he says without these
donations he would have nothing to eat
contributors too many students that are
going through depression because you
here to study and everything just become
very oppressive that you're trying to
study to get your grades and yet you
can't really achieve that in an empty
stomach nearly 80% of students at this
university fund their studies through
government financial aid or study loans
once their fees are paid there's little
money left to pay for accommodation or
buy food according to government
statistics unemployment and poverty are
highest among the youth many of these
students are the first in their families
to attend university many of them poor
this is not a problem that is relevant
to south africa alone all over the world
it sees what is aptly described as the
skeleton in university scoreboard
because you find that students all over
the world I mean also in developed
countries are facing hunger levels of up
to fifty eight percent of the population
in some countries as the US attorney
says some students are forced to trade
six with food or work long hours at low
paying jobs to feed themselves here at
the University of the vat vortice rant
about four thousand students are given
hot meals every day and hundreds food
packs every month but according to
research almost 1/3 of South African
students don't have enough food
organizers of the scheme to feed
students at this campus say they want to
provide food for students in a way that
doesn't stigmatize them the food program
at the Johannesburg University began six
years ago distributing food to about 50
students initially it was considered if
you like a band
problem bringing donations give handouts
to students and that will solve the
problem
we basically advanced an approach
through a signature eight thousand
signatures petitions March for hunger
and so on and demanded a space of
dignity for students at this university
while greater access to education is
meant to alleviate poverty and create
jobs there are concerns that hundreds of
students could drop out of university
every year simply because they're too
hungry to study femida mela al jazeera
Johannesburg South Africa